[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le bâtiment n'a l'air de rien du tout et
se fond au décor industriel de la
banlieue moisson mais derrière ces
barbelés se cache un véritable trésor
national
rares sont les journalistes et les
caméras qui peuvent y pénétrer
l'environnement est froid stérile et
ultra contrôler les dès que l'on
franchit les portes de ce laboratoire
secret de votre odeur des plus
réconfortante nous viennent presque
instinctivement vers la cuisine
principal ragoût de mouton qui mijote
explique fièrement victoire au losc il
est scientifique docteur et membre
honoraire de l'académie de l'espace en
russie 75 ans il n'a jamais mis les
pieds en orbite
n'empêche c'est lui qui nourrit les
cosmonautes depuis des décennies il
n'avait que 16 ans quand le premier
s'est envolé vers l'espace
on se souvient très bien de l'euphorie
google est parti avec neuf tube de
nourriture dont du boersch
évidemment pour 108 minutes de vol
c'était l'inconnu au togo ghana va venir
pour essayer ce n'est pas pour moi si à
l'époque personne ne savait comment le
système digestif réagi en apesanteur et
gagarine a été le premier à nous dire
que tout est normal que oui on peut
marcher
oui on peut avaler tout est ok ok victor
de bluff ce qui a donc dédié sa carrière
au développement des menus aussi
équilibré que variées pour les désormais
très long séjour de six mois à bord de
la station spatiale internationale
procédés spéciaux y compris la
déshydratation des à dinan nous permette
de préserver jusqu'à 90% de leur valeur
nutritive dont les produits sont ainsi
sécher il ne garde que 5% de leur
humidité et cela nous permet de diminuer
le poids et le volume des produits ce
qui est essentiel pour le transport ou
menchov à biot car l'époque de la
nourriture terme servi en tubes comme
ceci est bel et bien révolue ici on ne
s'en sert que pour les jus de fruits
le reste de la nourriture est emballé
sous vide comme ceux grue aux abricots
qui a passé des heures au congélateur
avant d'être séché au four à très haute
température est réduit à la consistance
de poutres américain des amériques et le
nourrissent leurs astronautes avec des
produits achetés en épicerie et ils ne
font qu adapter leurs emballages pour
l'espace
mais tous les astronautes du monde
entier comment de nos repas pour
compléter leur menu avant de s'envoler
nos sommes prado panini et c'est
exactement ce qu'a fait l'astronaute
canadien david saint-jacques que nous
avons joint dans les sports à la
nourriture sur
moi j'aime bien la nourriture russe
d'abord parce que ça me rappelle tout le
temps j'ai passé en russie pour
m'entraîner pour apprendre à piloter la
fusée soyouz
il ya des fameux pain et russe le pain
de sarrasin morceau de pain comme ça
j'adore ça c'est souvent un peu comme
des ragots des mélanges de viandes et de
légumes ici un espace et bien c'est
nourrissant peas et chaleureux alors que
david saint jacques se prépare à quitter
le cosmos sur terre on prépare déjà les
prochains ravitaillement pour la station
spatiale
voici à quoi ressemble deux semaines de
rations soit trois repas par jour et une
collation macédoine de légumes des
céréales avec du lait ceux-là de sécurit
la salade de betteraves nous tous réunis
pour tf1 c'est important dit nina
d'éviter la répétition ne veut surtout
pas que les astronautes s'attache un
plan particulier mais de tous ses repas
et il y en a des centaines
victor admet qu'il est particulièrement
fier de ce petit fromage blanc ou noir
donc tous les astronautes il n'y a pas
une seule expédition ce fromage n'est
pas demander même que depuis les vols
mixtes vers la station international des
amériques et sont prêts à échanger leurs
propres produits pour avoir ces rations
de fromage russe c'est devenu une devise
dans l'espace
d'abord ils vous ne serez pas étonné
d'apprendre non plus que toutes ces
recettes et leurs procédés sont
officiellement protégés par l'état -
news corp a bouclé son secret diminué
depuis
et nous ne les dévoileront janet
[Musique]